long lines high prices and car shortages
that's what we've been hearing when
people try to rent a car lately in vegas
the problem
spanning the nation after many rental
car companies forced to downsize during
the pandemic
reporter kate houston spoke to some
travelers about their experience
lines are forming as memorial day
travelers try to book a ride and while
some signs here say that cars are
available
a nationwide shortage is surging rates
at the mccarran rent-a-car center
travelers are hoping their reservation
went through
it was a hassle to go through like a lot
of like windows were opening my laptops
you know like
going to like trying to get a good deal
some booked months ahead of time
we knew vegas over memorial day would be
would be
would be busier and so we wanted to make
sure we had some transportation and not
have to rely on uber others went through
third party sites
all the agencies said they were sold out
no cars available
but getting here i was able to
go through priceline and reserve a car
while many were able to book a ride
it came at a cost seems like the cost of
the rental cars right now is
almost double what it used to be we were
trying to get a van or something like
that and
price was rocket high like it was high
high cars from enterprise
avis and hertz are ranging from 100 to
400 dollars a day
some travelers say theirs cost between
200 to 350 dollars
it takes away from other activities to
have to pay that kind of money
while there are frustrations some
travelers like nathan wills are being
patient
it is a memorial weekend so you know
coming off a cove it so
everybody took a big hit so a lot of
places are trying to
regroup and you know unfortunately we
have to pay for it but i can understand
kate houston 8 news now for those unable
to secure a ride mccarran international
airport encouraging travelers to utilize
ride share taxis and public
transportation within our city